es ist eines der größten mord rätsel auf
dass unsere reporter jemals gestoßen
sind und teilweise machen sie ihren job
seit 29 jahren tatort ingolstadt in
bayern eine leiche in einem auto
blutüberströmt mit mehr als 40
messerstichen und die eltern warnen
davor um ihre tochter so dachte man
zunächst aber es ist alles ganz anders
polizisten stochern im gras suchen nach
spuren sperren den tatort weiträumig ab
eine frau weint im hintergrund
es ist eine mutter sie trauert um ihre
vermeintlich tote tochter die 23 jährige
sarah bahn
mit mindestens 40 messerstichen soll die
deutsch irakerin auf dem rücksitz ihres
mercedes ermordet worden sein eigentlich
doch jetzt die unfassbare wendung in
diesem grausamen mord fall die
vermeintlich ermordete shaban ist gar
nicht tot
rückblick ingolstadt dienstagabend nach
einem treffen mit ihrem ex-mann können
schavans eltern ihre 23-jährige tochter
nicht erreichen voller sorge beginnen
ihre eltern die suche nach ihrer tochter
wenig später machen sie einen grausamen
fund ihre vermeintliche tochter liegt
blutüberströmt auf der rückbank ihres
mercedes die junge frau ist tot zuerst
kommt schavans ex mann ins visier der
ermittler wenig später entkräftet sich
jedoch der verdacht bei der
kriminaltechnischen untersuchung stellt
sich heraus bei der toten frau handelt
es sich gar nicht um shaban es ist eine
fast identisch aussehende 23-jährige
frau schavans doppelgängerin die
ermittler gehen davon aus dass die echte
shaban an dem mord beteiligt ist sie
nehmen shaban und einen mutmaßlich
ebenso beteiligten mann aus dem kosovo
fest das motiv noch unklar wollte shaban
ihren eigenen tod vortäuschen die
ermittlungen laufen auf hochtouren
dieses wort rätsel zu lösen
[Musik]